this next story is completely
unbelievable do you guys remember when
donald trump would talk during his
campaign
about how people are flushing toilets 10
to 15 times people are flushing toilets
10 times 15 times and we were wondering
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
that he's so obsessed with needing to
flush
10 to 15 times
we have now figured it out
and it is unbelievable
new york times reporter maggie haberman
writes in her forthcoming book
that trump's white house toilet
would be
clogged with documents that donald trump
was flushing down the toilet
um
this
is is this the explanation is this the
explanation
uh axios reports while president trump
was in office staff at the white house
residence trump was doing this with his
personal toilet
periodically would discover
wads of printed paper clogging a toilet
and believed that the president had
flushed pieces of paper maggie haberman
scoops in her forthcoming book
confidence man
this adds of i love this language this
adds a vivid new dimension to trump's
lapses in preserving government
documents
uh habermann reports trump has told
people that since leaving office he has
remained in contact with kim jong-un
whose love letters as trump once called
them were among documents the national
archives retrieved from mar-a-lago the
news of white house toilet flushing
comes as the national archives has asked
the biden justice department to examine
trump's handling of white house records
so let's go back remember this
bizarre viral rant from trump about
elements of bathrooms and 10 to 15
flushes we have a
situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
and other elements of bathrooms
where
uh
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly dripping out
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
it's so insane because people have been
sanctioned for far less document
destruction than what trump did so like
there's a very real story here guys
which is
trump ran on
hillary can't be trusted with with
documents with information she can't
private email all this different stuff
and meanwhile
trump is
eating documents according to omarosa
manago newman trump is ripping up
documents which then have to be taped
back together
trump's family is using private email
for government business trump takes
documents to mar-a-lago which is
subsequently taken back by the national
archives and trump is sitting there
flushing the toilet to flush documents
down the toilet so when trump says
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
what it means is i'm doing it i am just
flushing wads of documents down the
toilet and i'm needing
he's he's uh really exercising the
valves by flushing again and again and
again if you wrote this into a movie it
would be like it's too much of a
caricature no one would possibly believe
the president is literally flushing
documents down the white house toilet
clogging it and then having to get staff
to unclog the toilet from the documents
it's unbelievable
now on the serious piece of this at what
point is it time
to actually look at charges
for some of this document related stuff
sandy berger was a political consultant
was the uh u.s national security advisor
for bill clinton for a roughly four-year
period okay
he removed
four documents four documents and sandy
berger was
fined fifty thousand dollars
sentenced to two years probation had to
do a hundred hours of community service
and lost his security clearance for
three years
ultimately gave up his license to
practice law okay
four documents that sandy berger
inappropriately took with him and
you know we the intent may not even have
been nearly as as as pernicious as what
it seems that an insidious as what
donald trump is trying to do here
trump's flushing
documents down the toilet eating them
and ripping them up and taking them to
mar-a-lago
and it's not just trump there are other
people that were involved in improper
handling of records or private email all
of this different stuff at what point is
it time to say there have to be some
consequences here we'll have the clip of
trump
talking about
flushing toilets 10 to 15 times on our
instagram if you're just listening today
find us on instagram at david pakman
show
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive
daily nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us
ag-1 by athletic greens is a delicious
drink that just simplifies the entire
thing it's one product you get all of
the things you need 75 vitamins minerals
and whole food sourced ingredients it's
a multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's
a probiotic green food blend in one
daily serving really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything i'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes